le bassin méditerranéen est broyé par le
continent africain qui s'enfonce sous la
plaque eurasienne générant de complexes
faille de subduction prises entre les
deux la plaque adriatique tourne dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
à la vitesse de 3 mm par an autour de la
ville d'hama trichet et des villages
voisins de la chaîne montagneuse des
apennins au centre de l'italie 24 août
3h30 du matin
un tremblement de terre d'une magnitude
6,2 puissant bien que peu profonds fera
pas les villages les villes d'argoat à
préparer et pescara del tronto furent
parmi les plus violemment touchés dans
cette région le prêtre local francesco
armandi est la mémoire vivante de ce
village la nuit du 24 août à 3h36
précisément nous avons entendu un grand
fracas et la terre a tremblé de manière
violente
j'étais au lit mais réveillez et on
avait l'impression que la nature voulait
projeter mon lit au plafond j'ai attendu
la fin de la secousse je me suis habillé
rapidement et je suis sorti
les rues étaient pleines de gravats de
cailloux et de grosses pierres et toute
la population est sorti dans la rue je
me suis levé j'ai enfilé mes chaussons
j'ai pris mon fils et avant même la fin
de la première secousse
nous étions déjà dans l'escalier nous
étions justement sur le parking d'un
côté et on entendait le fracas des
pierres depuis la crête du veto ray qui
roulait jusqu'en bas avec la secousse du
tremblement de terre en dix minutes
tu regardes ce qu'il ya autour de toi tu
vois la désolation la maison et sur pied
mais si tu ne peux pas y vivre c'est
comme si tout s'était arrêté et voir ton
village qui n'existe plus c'est encore
plus dur
outre les pertes humaines une partie du
patrimoine culturel de l'italie fut
également ravagé une église s'est
écroulé à pescara b elle a certainement
milan elle ne s'était jamais écroulé
pourtant des tremblements de terre il y
en a déjà eu
ce qui veut dire que celui ci était
beaucoup plus violent il ne s'agit pas d
secousse colossale que l'on observe à la
lisière des plaques tectoniques où des
séismes de magnitude 8 et 9 peuvent se
produire dans cette région les failles
sont plutôt petites car peu profondes
mais quand le séisme se produit juste au
dessus la secousse est spectaculaire
nous nous sommes rendu compte que nous
étions de vrais miraculé parce qu'après
taré mais à part ça nous a parlé des
gars que nous voyons derrière nous il
n'y a pas eu de mort il n'y a pas eu de
blessés puis nous avons vu pescara alors
nous avons remonter nos manches
nous nous sommes dit que nous sommes
encore là et que nous pouvions faire
quelque chose ce qui est arrivé à
pescara c'est incroyable
[Musique]
le village malheureusement a été
complètement détruit d'ailleurs si vous
y allez vous ne verrez plus qu'un tas de
ruines
il ya eu près de 50 morts ces personnes
je les connaissais je les avait mariés
j'avais baptiser leurs enfants alors je
suis un peu sous le choc parce que quand
20 30 40 ou 50 ami meurt c'est forcément
un drame intérieur et une douleur
profonde
c'est sûr nous aurons certainement des
difficultés à nous reprendre pour
repartir
[Musique]
il